[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning happy football sunday
the votes have finally been counted and
i'm excited to let you know
that this governing body has the highest
number of winners only welcome to the
squad ride
presented by draftkings live in the
bleach report app my name is cabbie
richards
and in a league of legends she is in a
league of her own
that is kelly stewart and the newly
created running the newly created
department of legends
greg ivory good morning to you sir this
is a show where we bet on anytime
touchdowns
chosen by you the audience so when one
of those players takes it to the crib
we celebrate we are six and two in the
season and we gotta celebrate grandma
legend
let's give her a round of applause shout
out to graham shout out to grams
last week she picked tyrek hill to score
touchdown against the jets and it was so
nice tyrique scored twice
thank you again grandma earlier this
week we asked you on social who
is a lock to score touchdown in week
nine these are the pressing questions
that we ask you
here and we need answers and as always
as greg likes to say
we want winners baby these are some of
the most popular picks you've sent us
most of these guys scored touchdowns
last week i like that travis kelsey's on
the board
and shout out to josh jacobs too we've
narrowed it down to five legendary
videos though
that we're gonna show you and they keep
getting better so
thank you very much um you guys are
gonna disquiet
excuse me you guys are gonna decide our
week nine squad ride
so let's look at some of the videos you
sent us this week
and remember winners only
please
[Music]
all right bleacher report betting you're
locked for squad ride
jonathan tyler those going to touchdown
on sunday
[Music]
with derrick henry
much like when his favorite team is
handing out
w's to opponents jimmy generous greg
ivory likes to hand out hoodies
do what you came to do my friend
yes sir yes sir is it time capsule it's
time let's get it
it's time it's time i'm in these
comments giving away hoodies only for
good takes and good takes only uh i got
sloane
58 says kilatrav is an absolute luck he
and pat
are on a whole another level of
chemistry
you know i love chemistry i talk about
it all the time
and i'm rocking with that because i have
pat on my fantasy team so if travis
kelsey
is scoring touchdowns that means i'm
winning also sloan 58 you're walking
away
with the hoodie uh here we go i got geno
zero six zero three he says greg tampa
is a lot
winners only please cabbie he said the
please
so therefore i'm giving him a hoodie i'm
i mean he said the please you have to be
generous to the betting gods
uh here we go i got one more in me
cabbie one more
i got uh ali415
sf says dez bryant td scores
alvin and antonio scores as well
uh i don't know i don't know that was
it was you since cabbie likes it okay
ally you're walking away with a hoodie
uh cabbie i'm done
i'm done because i'm uh they're telling
me i got i got i got to stop so i'm done
loot to dez bryant and antonio brown we
should we might see them today which is
which is amazing
all right uh the king of the hill
contest begins you know how we do here
on squad ride let's get into round one
our first pitch comes from jake bodner
with a truly legendary inspiration
all right br betting we've got a big
week coming up
i know one thing is a lock thank you to
my friend mclovin
who do we got this week
dk metcalf anytime touchdown score is a
lock
guarantee it lock it in
anytime dk metcalf takes the field he's
super bad shout out to you all right so
here's his opponent
jake jesse bernstein
all right so i actually have a question
so do you follow football at all
all right this weekend anytime touchdown
score dk metcalf or mike evans
we're going dk all right perfect
if i'm video hi guys and uh can we also
get a coke please
before the video before the video took i
said your name because i just had to
jump in on
on mcla on the mclovin legend like my
guy
my guy my guy listen to me listen to me
mclovin's like 45 years old with three
grandkids by now like like we have to
give that up and like get a get a new
he okay he's still a legend but we have
to get a new poster my god i love
i love the video though i do love the
video i love the pic
i don't know if you guys know this but
we have dk metcalf versus dk metcalf
for the first time here on the squad
ride so we're just
we're just looking at these videos and
trying to see which one's better
let me talk about the drive-through
legend right now so my guy he pulled up
to the drive-through
he pulled up to the drive-thru and uh he
asked a question that reminded me of
something i would have done back in the
day when i was a little a little
younger it was it was pretty funny but
let's talk about the end of the video
he he ordered a coke he ordered a coke
he didn't even ask his lady if she if
she wanted if she wanted some food
how do you get a chick-fil-a hey
you don't go to chick-fil-a and not
order the number two deluxe
spicy chicken with uh with fries like
with the
with the lemonade like you don't you
just don't do it
our dude was on a mission he just wanted
to figure out who's going to score the
first touchdown maybe it was like
not even dinner or lunch time and he
just wanted a coke leave him alone
all right kelly talk about the pick
they're facing uh
the the seattle seahawks is facing the
bills they're
in buffalo talk talk to me you think
he's going to score today
uh you know this is interesting because
this buffalo defense does have a
decent secondary their problem is they
can't stop the run
this one's hard for me because i'm on
the bills plus three here
seattle's in this interesting scheduling
predicament i like to call
the sandwich spot so who do they just
play greg they just played your niners
and before that they just lost
to the arizona cardinals they have to
fly to the east coast
now to play in buffalo in a game that
doesn't really matter to them to turn
around
and play the rams and then a revenge
game
on thursday night against the cardinals
i don't know what to make of this game i
understand that buffalo has been left
for dead in the afc east
but i do not think that this is at all
respectful given three at
home this makes no sense i'm on buffalo
here
thus i don't want dk makeup to score a
touchdown at all
it's gonna be hard to stop kelly i'm
kelly and cabby i'm in the comments yes
cabbie it is gonna be hard to stop him
he's turning into one of the best
receivers in the league
um and and and the comments are agreeing
with me i see a lot of takes on dk
metcalves uh running over everybody
today shout out to tanika plan88
uh i'm giving away hoodies now cabbie uh
uh i got 4k trey sandy k
is going to have a monster game 4k
uh man i mean we're riding with you i'm
going to send you a hoodie
uh i have bay area guy 87 says oh my god
number two with the lemonade is my
favorite on my family
we're like twins greg yes yes
yes shout out to chick-fil-a yes all
right you're walking away with a hoodie
that's sunday we can't even get
chick-fil-a can you knock it off i'm
getting hungry
good point that's a great point that's a
great point kelly
but but cabbie kelly i'm seeing a lot of
drive-through i'm seeing drive-through
throughout the comments
they're rocking with the drive-through
legend moving on
to the next round uh he's representing
dk
i like it i like that all right okay
shout out to jesse bernstein the
drive-through legend you've made it
through round one
but as you know how this game goes you
have three more quarters to win
before becoming the squad rod legend
round two
let's get it the next pitch is from the
game
sorry the gaming tables with larosa 23.
roll the dice my man
what up bleacher report nation we're
gonna roll some dice to see who at an
anytime touchdown score is going to be
this sunday
we're looking for a point
four stephon diggs
you heard from the craps like boom roll
to four tell us in the comments
who should move on to round three so
right um
greg you create most of the most of the
videos on br so
social shout out to winners only
wednesdays you do a great job with that
yes sir what did you think about this
pitch
cabbie you know me whenever i'm in vegas
i'm always on the dice table that is my
game
i love this video but my my guy he wrote
a four he wrote a four that's okay
that's in the field
you know that's in the field he wrote a
four i can work with that you know i
like to play the six the eight
maybe the ten maybe the nine so you know
i can work with the four roll but let's
talk about the pick let's talk about the
pick
stefan diggs is taking on that seattle
seahawks defense now cabbie against the
49ers that defense
looked it they they looked like the the
seattle defensive old i'm not gonna lie
is that going to happen this week
against the buffalo bills
i do not know kelly talk to me we got
stefan dix we got dk metcalf facing off
against each other
what are we riding with greg as far as
the video goes
i love the dude i'm a field roller
myself i know it's a bad bet but i
always have to play the field when the
dice are my hands so if you're a six and
eight guy greg
don't ever roll dice with me you'll hate
me we'll be there for 30
30 minutes but that being said a lot of
you guys don't know but i've always
preached that i hate fantasy football
why do i hate fantasy football because i
hate going against my bets
i have a buffalo bills plus three ticket
in my pocket
how can i pick dk metcalf it just can't
happen
those two things do not correlate i'm
rocking with stefan diggs plus 145 here
you hate fantasy football kelly but you
play fantasy football
it doesn't matter gabby it is the worst
feeling
on the planet to have running back a
and a ticket on the other team and you
need this guy to score to win your game
but you need this
guy not to score to cash your ticket it
is not a fun place to be
so yes my bets take precedence over
fantasy football
one of the most fun places to be are in
the comments stefan diggs dk metcalf
g-money how is the audience reacting to
these two videos
cabbie the audience is back and forth
back and forth a
lewis 18 says diggs will be a match-up
nightmare against that seattle secondary
i just got done talking about it
you're walking away with hoodie that was
a good take uh
uh let me uh the the o26 ui
says give me dk with a number two and
fry's on the side
uh so they're back and forth cab either
back and forth i'm gonna make the call
here i'm gonna make the call here
uh tanika plan is back in the comments
jeff bonds about the dig graves
for seahawks corners so it looks like i
mean
i i i see a lot of digs betting bucks
betty bucks greg
diggs is a lock homie seattle d is weak
he's getting in
bedding buck you're walking away with
the hoodie it looks like uh
we're rocking with stefan diggs in the
crafts legend captain okay all right big
shout out to larosa 23 coming through
with the four
he moves on to round three two rounds
down
let's get it our next opponent is ian st
dizzier who did some serious thinking
about his pitch
[Music]
ian st dizzying beautiful mind beautiful
pick with derek henry
g money how do you feel about this video
with our scholarly gabby i'm
i'm i'm taken away by the scholar legend
i mean he
we might need to nominate him for an
oscar or something this is like a short
a short movie that we just saw a steven
spielberg produced movie it was it was
really put
put together very well i mean i'm i'm
impressed i'm impressed now let's talk
about the pick here
let's talk about the pick derrick henry
derek henry is facing that chicago's
bears defense
uh i mean we've been riding with derek
henry on the squad ride it seems like
almost every
week i mean the guy's been in the end
zone almost every week
i actually like this pick derek henry uh
and we're gonna change that
that minus 240 to plus 300 i like this
kelly talk to me stefan diggs derek
henry what are you
thinking look derek henry one of the
best running backs in the league
maybe christian mccaffrey has something
to say about that today but all jokes
aside
this bear's defense is really really
good now i know bookmakers haven't given
them much respect
they catch the best bet for us last week
i think this is going to be a tough
matchup the titans
now on a two-game losing streak have a
chance to bounce back here at home
and how are they going to do what they
need derek henry to get the run game
going takes him that pressure off
tannehill
i'm with you greg i think derrick henry
especially at three to one
we got to take him here
cabbie yes kelly i'm in the comments i
am in the comments
my uh m silver sport says still going
with crabsleven
craps legend i'm sorry big game from
diggs today
just watch we riding him all the way in
the 10
plus reception game let's get that
hoodie greg
i love the take i love the take here so
uh m silver sport you're going to be
walking away
with the hoodie 4k trey says a scholar
legend put his time into this one
yes scholar legend did put his time
into this one um cabbie it's back and
forth in the comments it is back and
forth in the comments
uh give me another one nico madrid
exciting vote
nico we okay i got you nico madrid
scholar legend for the win henry
easy money uh cabbie
it looks like derrick henry and the
scholar legend is is is
moving on i mean i'm seeing a lot of
henry and and i'm making the call
i'm making the call i got one more jazz
man 1134
derek henry is an easy pick although the
bears defense is amazing
it it has a horrible run defense
you're walking away with hoodie for that
take uh cabbie we are
riding with derrick henry and the
scholar legend moving on to the next
round
listen derek henry scored a touchdown in
five straight games so that is
that's a pretty good pick ian say
dizzier okay so three we're three
quarters down it's almost time to
declare our squad ride
voted by you the audience let's head
into the final round ian
saint desier the scholarly legend we're
bringing derek henry
to face our final pitch from riley sorbo
and his foul friends
let's see what the farm picks are yep
yep go pick who's gonna score the first
touchdown
who should be the squad squad ride
squad ride is alvin kamara lock it in
yes that chicken is scooped and scored
there at the end did you see he just
picked up the whole thing of cheese and
just
ran off interception that's it that's a
veteran move
uh tell us in the comments whether
you're riding with the chickens and
alvin
kamara or our scholar legend ian st
dizier with the derrick henry pick uh
g-money what'd you think of our final
pitch
and have you been to a farmer oh of
course cabbie i've been to
a farm before but i just want to say old
macdonald had a farm
e-i-e-i-o uh here we go
the old macovic legend is so legendary
like i'm at loss for words
but i i i just want to know like what
did you feed those chickens that looked
like blocks of cheese does chicken eat
did chickens eat cheese like
they looked like he was feeding his
chicken's cheese i'm really curious as
to what he was feeding those chickens
but the execution of the video was
stellar it was stellar to actually get
chickens to like you know
do what you want them to do anyway alvin
kamara he's been a
killer in fantasy he's been one of the
best backs in the league
for a couple years now kelly what do you
think
he's facing tampa bay today tampa bay
defense
alvin kamara uh he's sitting that minus
125 you know what the odds moves we're
gonna
boost it up to plus 300. talk to me
alvin kamara
derek henry what are you thinking oh
greg great great greg i want to comment
so bad but
this last game is my best bet so you
guys are just gonna have to wait
okay all right well how do you feel
about kamara though
counts i mean i coupled with everything
greg just said he's great
he's not only one of the best running
backs in the league he's also one of the
best slot receivers in the league
there's nothing to deny there if you're
gonna make me pick
between the two i gotta go with derrick
henry here
uh this is tough that bucks defense
might really step up today in a big way
okay well get in the comments let us
know who you're riding with alvin kamara
or derek henry while you do that back to
back weeks
week seven week eight they cash kelly
well done
please give the people your best bet for
week nine
you guys didn't even have to wait that
long i wanted that to be one of the
first videos he had to wait all show all
jokes aside
this best bet is really interesting why
because draftkings just moved us to
minus three and a half that means
money's coming on the saints
i get that the saints deserve a little
bit of respect here i took them week one
versus the same tampa bay team
and guess what they absolutely own tom
brady he even threw a pick
six now we flash forward to week nine
and things are a lot different i know
the saints have now won four straight
i was against them last week i was
against them the week of before so why
not make it
three in a row here i'm taking tom brady
and the tampa bay bucks that receiving
court and of course
that defense we will see sean payton get
out coached by bruce aryan today
the bucks is my best bet get on
draftkings lock it in tb12 with a new
weapon in a b
this week uh taven base looking to end
that new orleans saints four game win
streak and take advantage
of drew brees's sore right shoulder
thank you to our mvp kelly stewart we
are
riding with that best bet g-money
it's about that time sir yes sir what is
our squad
sir who is our new lock legend
all right here we go here we go cabbie
i'm in the comments going back and forth
uh they're all over the place in the
comments marky mark nine
seven five said henry is gonna eat all
of those chickens for lunch today
and add a couple goats to the meal wow
he's gonna be really really really
hitting mark
uh marky mark you're walking away with
the hoodie uh
it's jaylon says henry is too much of a
beast
yes it's jay lit henry is a beast he has
been scoring a lot
this week uh here we go um cabbie it's
back and forth it is back and forth from
the comments i guess i have to make a
decision
although i i got one mikey draco says
that cheddar that chicken
all i'm hearing is big money winner only
winners only kamara
you're walking away with a hoodie mikey
draco uh
it's back and forth cabbie i'm okay i'm
gonna make the decision right here
smoke a valley bad weather in florida
with rain and wind
bucks got a good defense you roll with
henry
the tank here so guess what
i made the decision the graphic is on
the board
switch the graphic derek henry is
right we are riding with derek henry uh
today
let's get on the squad ride make sure
you guys tune in to the br
uh instagram story where i'm gonna be
there and i need
winners only please send in your videos
we are gonna be riding derrick henry
hard
uh we're we're we're six and two on the
year we're doing good
we're doing good i mean come on man
right what this uh
yes go let's go let's go i'm juice
cabbie i'm ready to put this in right
now
excellent just hold on one second uh for
you guys watching
make sure to hit br betting social
channels for the link
to that odds boost send us your
screenshots your winners
send us more videos we love them and as
greg always says we want winners only
please so good luck with your wages
including three big one o'clock games to
start week nine
and uh tap in with our dude jimmy
generous aka wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
hold on hold on hold on on that on that
note
on that note you know what i gotta do i
gotta get back into the comments we got
to give away just a little bit more
hoodies
here we go ben mack
i don't know we're going to see ben mack
uh
ben mack i lost your hoodie i lost i
lost give him a hoodie because i lost it
i lost his
his comment but give him a hoodie uh
nico madrid need that hoodie greg it's
cold and dirty
good episode today easy lock nico you're
walking away with a hoodie
here we go uh here we go cabbie i got
a med man d-e-l-n
says derek henry is not human guess what
since you think he's not human and we're
riding with him today
you're walking away with a hoodie cabbie
i can keep going if you want me to
i can keep going if you want me to all
you got to do is just
say the word brother okay
hoodie one more hoodie and then okay
let's get okay because the games are
kicking off soon one more hoodie
okay okay here we go here we go steelers
kb he says hammer henry
and that's what we're doing steelers kb
you're walking away with a hoodie we are
hammering derrick henry here
uh cabbie i'm done man
i'm done giving away hoodies i'm done
king henry
king henry lead us to seven and two on
the squad ride thank you to all the
hoodie winners
thank you to all the commenters thank
you to all our legends jake bodner jesse
bernstein larosa 23
ian st dizzier and riley sorbo and your
chickens much appreciated
and everyone else who sent us videos if
they weren't featured on today's show
you got next week to be a legend and you
got a few more weeks to be alleged so
keep coming keep that creativity up
alongside
kelly stewart greg ivory my name is
cabbie richards thank you so much
for watching the squad ride here on
bleacher report
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign